- This is my favorite story, y'all,
because this happens a lot in families,
where people, they don't,
especially not coming from the south,
and people don't grow up
around the gay culture,
so they're kind of thrown by it,
and they don't know how
to handle it at first,
and I love y'all--
- Absolutely.
- So much for sharing this story,
it's gonna inspire so many people,
but were you always into makeup?
Were you--
- I was actually always into makeup.
I loved it, I loved seeing my
mom transform in the morning,
I loved seeing her turn into Superwoman.
I could see the transformation in her.
She felt more confident, she
loved it, and I was like,
"Oh my God, mom, this is
amazing," and I loved it.
- I love that, all right,
did you struggle with
Manny's interest at first?
- I definitely did.
Growing up in a Latino household,
the LGBT community
discussions never happened.
It was something new to me, so,
I had a real hard time understanding it,
and accepting it, and--
- 'Cause you didn't grow up around it.
- No, I did not.
- You grew up in a
completely different world.
- Exactly, exactly--
- Yeah.
- So it was very rough.
- So, Eva, beauty acceptance is a
big part of your brand,
do you relate to this?
- Oh, completely, especially
what you were talking about.
My mother is my biggest
beauty inspiration.
- [Manny] Same.
- And those memories of watching her,
transform is a perfect word.
She used to work at the
Hollywood Chinese Theater.
- [Kelly] Yeah?
- And back in the 80s,
I'd go to work with her,
and she had to wear the very Chinese,
I don't know what the proper word is--
- The ensemble that they were
in, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- That gown with the
high collar, and the red,
and I would watch, and we'd be on the bus.
It would be super not elegant,
except she would be this--
- Beacon, yeah.
- This thing, and so that inspired me,
and continues to inspire me,
that image of my mother
being this goddess.
- Absolutely.
- I hope my daughter thinks I'm a goddess.